gelatine ein billiges abfallprodukt der
fleischindustrie für viele ein no go
die industrie liebt und nutzt es wo sie
nur kann
unter anderem in unserem frischkäse
aber wieso eigentlich und darf das
überhaupt noch als frischkäse verkauft
werden wie die industrie mit gelatine
trickst zeigt sebastian lege
[Musik]
wer tricksen will muss das original
canon für sebastian geht's auf den hof
von kaiserin hilde schiller
sie macht ihren frischkäse ganz
traditionell braucht also nur milch
start der kultur und einen tag zeit
wenn ich kann das jetzt richtig gut
[Musik]
da nicht frisch leichte säure warst du
mal mehr träumen gar nicht schlecht
dauert aber zu lange sebastian hat einen
trick event aber gleiche variante machen
wo ich aus wenig frischkäse man ganz
viel frischkäse mache mit dem einen oder
anderen trick und ich dadurch auch noch
einen anderen preis erzielen kann
für sebastians version ist es besser die
herstellung nach draußen zu verlegen
sicher ist sicher wir verwenden nämlich
gas stickstoff bei der sorgt dafür dass
es unserem frischkäse das doppelte
volumen erzeugt wird na dann
pampel tab sebastian das ziel billiger
discounter frischkäse soll nicht nur
gestreckt werden sondern auch flori
schmecken dazu erstmal alles mit molke
verdünnen als abfallprodukt ist die
super billig dann fährt sebastian mal
wieder schwere geschütze auf
[Musik]
ein propeller am bohrer soll stickstoff
unter den frischkäse pumpen und den
schön fluffig machen volumen schon mal
richtig gekommen aber er sachen tekin zu
flüssig so flüssig das ist das stichwort
für die gelatine
die gelatine ist halt der kleine
zaubermeister an dem trick sie bindet
den frischkäse und hält so das neue
volumen zusammen aus flüssig macht
fluffig aus dem discounter frischkäse
haben wir die doppelte menge frischkäse
zubereitung erzeugt das könnten wir
jetzt in den markt bringen als luftig
lockere käsecreme ja der wolken genuss
der dir morgen den kuss auf die wange
gibt da ja oder ein gedicht auch für die
hersteller
sie verkaufen die luftigen produkte mit
gelatine im schnitt sogar fast 60
prozent teurer als normalen frischkäse
das ist ganz nach sebastians geschmack
hat nur leider mit richtigem frischkäse
nicht mehr viel zu tun und darf sich
daher auch nicht zu nennen laut käser
verordnung ist das nur noch eine
frischkäse zubereitung dennis stecken
bis zu 30 prozent andere zutaten mit
drin
so viel heiße luft muss man doch
schmecken im teste tritt sebastians
frischkäse zubereitung auf der grünen
sehr werte gegen den echten frischkäse
von hilde auf der roten an was sagen
unsere tester quote ist cremig und auch
echt gut aber der grüne ist cremig
unterhalten sich über stimmen des market
findet sich genau sagen was wir an aber
schmeckt mir besser
der grüne ist wesentlich
mir schmeckt der käse auf dem grün ist
nicht ganz
für unsere tester ist die sache klar
aber wahre käse expertin erkennen doch
wohl den unterschied
cremiger
meine meinung
oder auch nicht
das endergebnis 13 zu 2 stimmen für
sebastians gestreckte frischkäse
zubereitung
da kann man mal wieder sehen wie die
industrie den geschmack der gesellschaft
erzieht echten frischkäse kennt kaum
einer die frischkäse zubereitung mit
gelatine verdickungsmittel bis die molke
das schmeckt den leuten schön cremig
abgebunden ja wer echten frischkäse
möchte schon einfach mal auf die
zutatenliste übrigens gelatine kommt
selbst bei fruchtsäften zum einsatz
damit werden trübstoffe herausgefiltert
wenn du also auch gelatine in deinem
saft verzichten willst solltest du auf
das vegan siegel achten neue tricks
checks und duelle der zdf besser es gibt
es jeden dienstag und donnerstag auf
unserem kanal
wir wollen nichts verpassen dann
aktiviert die glocke neben eurem
abonnieren -button